The 1992 movie “Candyman” still remains
an influential piece of horror cinema.
Now, the highly anticipated sequel in the
franchise is almost here.
For the fans who have been waiting patiently,
here’s everything we know so far.
"Candyman" has seen quite a bit of reshuffling
over the last year.
Universal originally planned for the horror
sequel to come out in June 2020, but by April
of that year, the studio pushed it back in
the schedule.
The studio set a new, aspirational release
date for September of that year, but it had
to switch dates several more times before
it landed at its current date of August 27,
2021.
It looks like "Candyman" will stick with that
date, but we can never be too sure with these
things.
As far as we know, "Candyman" will come out
exclusively in theaters upon its initial release.
A ton of studios have begun experimenting
with dual theater and streaming service release
strategies.
Still, it looks like Universal wants people
to have the chance to see the newest horror
flick on the big screen, at least initially.
There's no official word yet regarding when
or where the slasher flick will be available
to view at home, but it's likely to follow
the standard progression from theaters to
pay-per-view VOD to subscription streaming.
So, don't expect to watch it from your home
until it's concluded the standard theatrical
run.
Some films are delayed for creative reasons.
Nothing makes a fanbase nervous like a round
of reshoots, and if they're extensive enough,
they can definitely inspire a little schedule
shuffling.
Fortunately, that wasn't the case with "Candyman."
The original June 2020 release was rendered
unworkable by the budding pandemic.
Universal clearly didn't want to drop a highly-anticipated
tentpole film on a country full of empty theaters.
So, the first delay came down just as the
pandemic was picking up speed, pushing "Candyman"
back an overly optimistic five months to September.
The next delay, sadly, was also a result of
the ongoing pandemic.
The has pandemic dragged on into 2021, and
continues to drag on in many places around
the world.
Theaters around the world were still shuttered
as of 2021, so instead of kicking the film
to VOD, Universal pushed the release date
again and again, eventually landing on August
27.
With the domestic vaccine rollout significantly
stemming the tide of the pandemic, and lockdown
orders lifting just about everywhere in the
U.S., it now seems almost certain that the
August release date will hold.
Unless something totally unforeseen happens
between now and then, expect "Candyman" to
roll into a theater near you alongside the
dog days of summer.
Fans of the original "Candyman" movies can
expect to see a few familiar faces among the
cast.
Most notably, Tony Todd reprises his role
as the title slasher.
The Candyman himself is a terrifying spirit
who visits anyone who dares to say his name
five times while looking into a mirror.
With a rusty hook as a hand and a propensity
for bees, he's one of the scariest horror
movie monsters to grace the big screen.
Another original actor to return includes
Vanessa Estelle Williams, who plays Anne-Marie
McCoy in both movies.
You may remember her from the 1992 film as
Anthony's mother, who spoke with a college
student about the urban legend surrounding
the monster within Chicago's Cabrini-Green
community.
Anthony is all grown-up for the follow-up,
and Yahya Abdul-Mateen II portrays him this
time around.
He's now a visual artist living in the newly-gentrified
area of town, where he explores the myth of
Candyman to find inspiration for his art.
The impressive cast for the upcoming horror
flick also includes such talented actors as
Teyonah Parris from "WandaVision," Colman
Domingo from "Ma Rainey's Black Bottom," and
Nathan Lloyd Stewart-Jarrett from "Mope."
Given that 2021's "Candyman" doesn't have
a subtitle or any numbers in the title, it
might be easy for audiences to assume it's
a remake of the original.
Rest assured, it's a sequel that picks up
several decades after the first film's events.
The two movies even share a connection by
making the little boy Candyman kidnapped the
protagonist of this follow-up.
As for the 2021 film, the plot follows Anthony,
played by Abdul-Mateen II, as he seeks to
find a way to rejuvenate his art career.
One day, he meets with an older member of
the community who was once a resident of the
Cabrini Green projects.
This person tells him the haunting story of
Candyman, which Anthony then uses as inspiration
for his paintings.
However, the deeper he goes into exploring
the concept of Candyman, the more he'll unleash
a horrific wave of murders.
The director of the 2021 film, Nia DaCosta,
appeared in a video interview in which she
discussed her approach to "Candyman" in depth.
The director is clearly a kindred spirit with
her latest collaborator, Jordan Peele.
DaCosta confirms that she shares Peele's firmly
held belief that horror is a perfect vehicle
for the exploration of social issues like
racial and class inequities.
She pointed out in the interview that the
creation of monsters is hardly the sole province
of genre fiction.
DaCosta says,
"We create monsters of men all the time.
People are murdered and they become either
saints or they are vilified.
So, throughout the last year and a half, it
was always coming back to that truth.
Horror is a really effective tool when it
comes to telling stories about things that
impact us on a social level.
The very function of it is to make you uncomfortable
and I think if that discomfort is attached
to explorations of race or gender you have
to then reconcile your feelings about race
and gender."
Given the vocal sentiments of DaCosta and
horror maestro Jordan Peele, expect a healthy
serving of the latter's signature blend of
frights and social commentary to be on abundant
display.
"Candyman" is one horror film that will leave
you thinking twice before you stare too long
at a mirror and say,
"Candyma--"
“Shhh!
Don’t.
Don’t say that.”
We already know that "Candyman" 2021 has been
pulled forward into the modern day.
As a result, we can expect the film to grapple
with contemporary issues of anti-Black racism
in America, using the popular discourse of
the time.
Peele has also described this film as a "spiritual
sequel" to the original "Candyman," one that
will likely capture the mood of the original
better than any of its less-lauded direct
sequels.
For a hint at how Peele's new vision might
look, we turn to Universal's extensive synopsis
of the forthcoming film.
Universal revealed,
"For as long as residents can remember, the
housing projects of Chicago's Cabrini-Green
neighborhood were terrorized by a word-of-mouth
ghost story about a supernatural killer with
a hook for a hand, easily summoned by those
daring to repeat his name five times into
a mirror.
In present day, a decade after the last of
the Cabrini towers were torn down, visual
artist Anthony McCoy and his girlfriend, gallery
director Brianna Cartwright, move into a luxury
loft condo in Cabrini, now gentrified beyond
recognition and inhabited by upwardly mobile
millennials.”
Universal further explained, saying,
“With Anthony's painting career on the brink
of stalling, a chance encounter with a Cabrini
Green old-timer exposes Anthony to the tragically
horrific nature of the true story behind Candyman.
Anxious to maintain his status in the Chicago
art world, Anthony begins to explore these
macabre details in his studio as fresh grist
for paintings, unknowingly opening a door
to a complex past that unravels his own sanity
and unleashes a terrifying wave of violence
that puts him on a collision course with destiny.”
It's worth noting that though the Cabrini-Green
neighborhood still exists, the real-life Cabrini-Green
Rowhouse projects were torn down in 2011.
The Cabrini-Green housing projects were infamous,
and provided an iconic backdrop to the original
1992 "Candyman."
Just how the new film will grapple with the
changing face of the neighborhood is unknown,
but count on Jordan Peele to find an interesting
way to weave the complex social fabric of
present-day Chicago into aesthetic or plot
devices to the thesis of this film.
After over a year of delays, there better
be a trailer.
Fortunately, Universal has released not just
one, but two full-length trailers to keep
viewers excited about the film over the course
of the excruciating wait.
Both trailers, taken in tandem, tease a terrifying
and relevant film marked by immaculate acting,
direction, and cinematography.
The first trailer, released back in February
2020 when that original June release date
still seemed like a possibility, shows off
quite a bit of the two killer leads, Yahya
Abdul-Mateen II and Teyonah Parris.
We also get a glimpse of a bunch of teenagers
lined up in what looks like a school bathroom,
summoning the titular Candyman, while standing
in front of a mirror.
You know, like you're supposed to do it.
Minor spoiler alert: It doesn't end well for
the teens.
The second trailer, which only dropped on
June 23, 2021, takes an even creepier approach.
It opens with a bit of animated shadow puppetry
to accompany a voiceover explaining the Candyman
mythology and hinting at the danger that will
be summoned in the film.
Interestingly, the plot of the original Candyman
film seems to serve as the lore underpinning
the contemporary story.
The voiceover sets up the razor blades-in-the-candy
scenario from the earlier film, as quick intercuts
of the animated shadow puppets continue to
intrude to eery effect.
For the fans that want to see how these things
are all pulled together and the ones who just
want a few good scares, “Candyman” is
almost here.
We’ll just have to make our way into the
theatres for the experience.
“Say his name.”
Looks like we're going to finally find out
what happens when they do in theaters on August
27.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about upcoming
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.